hi i'm a scientist but don't be
intimidated
in fact by the end of this video i want
you to question everything
i say i'm an astronomer
strangers are often excited to meet me
oh you're an astronomer
i'm a pisces what's my horoscope i
usually roll my eyes and dramatically
pronounce
well there will be conflict in the
middle east partisan bickering in
congress and
fluctuations in the stock market but in
truth confusing astronomy with astrology
is excusable since
the first astronomers were astrologers
astrologers believed there was a link
between heavenly bodies like the sun
moon and planets
and our affairs on earth early
astrologers correlated the sun's motion
across the sky with seasonal changes
this in turn allowed farmers to optimize
the planting of their crops
even johannes kepler whose three laws of
planetary motion
are still in use today and after whom
nasa named a satellite
he even dabbled in astrology as well
so what's wrong with astrology why isn't
it taught at our top universities
because it isn't science and its
practitioners aren't scientists
instead astrologers confuse correlation
the position of the sun and the sky
with causation crop yields which is as
close to a cardinal sin as exists in
science
so what is science strictly speaking
there isn't a strict definition
but since the 1600s it's been accepted
that scientists should practice
the scientific method the scientific
method is the most marvelous tool for
knowledge generation ever devised
the method involves systematic
observation and experimentation
formulation of hypotheses deductions
about those hypotheses
experimental testing of the deduction
and presentation to other experts
often this is done in an adversarial
fashion known as peer review
iterate this process for a few decades
or hundreds of years and if things
stand the test of time you just might be
doing science
now how does astrology fare against this
rubric
observations and measurements check
hypothesis
check testing check if you notice
your local newspaper probably devotes
more space to astrology than astronomy
so perhaps the scientific method is
insufficient
to augment the scientific method the
eminent philosopher carl popper
suggested a brilliant addendum
popper said that a subject is scientific
if and only if it can be
falsified let that sink in falsified
not proven popper said that it must be
possible for a claim to be proven
wrong that is falsified to ascertain
whether
that discipline was scientific or not
popper said astrologers prophecies were
sufficiently vague
that they in his words were able to
explain away
anything that might have been a
refutation of their theory
had the prophecies they made been more
precise
in order to escape falsification they
destroyed the testability
of their theory so if your theory is
untestable
if it can't be proven wrong it's
probably not science
so it's simple trust scientists who can
be proven
wrong well not so fast
it depends on what you mean by trust if
by trust you mean obey
you should probably think a second time
for example
aristotle was a scientist he observed
that whales were mammals not fish
he codified the rules of logic and
philosophy that are still
used 2 300 years after his death
but he also believed there were only
four elements when there are actually
over a hundred
he believed the earth was the center of
the universe it isn't
and he believed that heavier objects
fall faster than lighter ones
they don't galileo falsified most of
what the great
aristotle said showing there is no place
for authority
in science scalio said in questions of
science
the authority of a thousand is not worth
the humble reasoning
of a single individual yet even galileo
had a share of blunders
including hypothesizing that comets were
in the earth's atmosphere
they aren't and that the tides on the
earth's
oceans are caused by its motion around
the sun
instead of the true cause the moon's
gravitational pull
isaac newton was a scientist he
developed calculus
discovered the law of universal
gravitation codified
the laws of optics and much much more he
also practiced
alchemy was sympathetic to astrology and
spent a fair amount of time
torturing and executing counterfeiters
fritz haber was a scientist
he was a german jew born in 1868 haber
invented the chemical process that
enabled you to eat breakfast this
morning
he won the nobel prize in chemistry for
inventing a fertilizer production method
that today
feeds half of the population he was also
fiercely nationalistic in world war one
haber led a special chemical warfare
unit
he recruited fellow scientists including
three future nobel laureates
to serve as gas troops alongside him
haber insisted on witnessing horrific
chlorine gas warfare by the german army
in 1915
which claimed tens of thousands of
allied lives
three years later haber won the nobel
prize and he never expressed remorse
for his role in immoral war crimes
crimes that germany itself had signed
onto
the league of nations prohibition
against in 1908
haber later would go on to invent an
insecticide
called zyklon b a decade after his death
the nazi's final solution used tons of
that poison gas
at auschwitz and treblinka among those
killed
and those gas chambers were members of
haber's
own family more recently
scientist james watson co-recipient of
the 1962 nobel prize in physiology or
medicine
for discovering dna's double helix
structure horrifically said he was
gloomy about
africa because all of our social
policies are based on the fact that
their
intelligence is the same as ours
watson also suggested that rich people
should be paid to have children because
if there is any correlation he said
between success and genes
iq will fall if the successful people
don't have children
william shockley was a scientist he
co-invented the transistor
the very device that powers the screen
you're watching this video
on later he mendaciously claimed
that the major cause of the american
negroes
intellectual and social deficits is
hereditary
and racially genetic in origin and thus
not remediable
by improvements in the environment
these disgusting ideas all promulgated
by scientists
some of whom won nobel prizes should
they be trusted
should we obey their proclamation no
matter how odious they are
obviously not we might want to listen to
their opinions
in the scientific realm about
fertilizers dna
and transistors but their repugnant
moral opinions on race
on warfare on social policy it's
disgusting to even consider
as italian philosopher of science
marcelo pera has shown
science advances as scientists argue
about how to interpret evidence
premature appeals to an alleged
consensus or authority
can short-circuit the necessary
deliberation
and lead to unwarranted conclusions
impeding scientific advances
the false perception of scientific
consensus or authority by individuals
perceived as brilliant
can form the basis of rigidly enforced
authoritarian policy
so scientists are supposed to be domain
experts not ethical
experts that's why we in democratic
countries elect politicians
not to submit to rule by scientific
experts that are unelected
nobel laureate richard feynman cautioned
his fellow scientists
the first principle is that you must not
fool yourself
and you are the easiest person to fool
feynman added that scientists should go
to great lengths to show
not only how they're likely to be right
but how they could possibly be
wrong he said doing so is
our quote responsibility as scientists
certainly to other scientists
but also to laymen as well you can
judge a society by who it chooses to
venerate for generations
people have rightfully looked to
scientists as merchants of truth
keepers of facts walking wikipedias
in fact the word science comes from the
latin cientia
meaning knowledge but knowledge doesn't
equal wisdom
as the old saying goes knowledge is
knowing a tomato is a fruit
but wisdom is knowing not to put it in a
fruit salad
because the public trusts scientists
subject matter expertise
their knowledge lay people often feel
scientists wisdom
is also unimpeachable and unbiased but
the opposite is true
studies show scientists are among the
most polarized members of society when
it comes to policy on controversial
issues
like abortion stem cell research and
climate change unlike the discovery of a
far-off exoplanet
which is fascinating but not impactful
on our daily lives
obeying scientific opinion about hot
button social issue
just because we are scientists is an
example
of the unwarranted halo effect bias
science is always provisional and
politicizing it is bad for science
what one politician sees as expert
wisdom another
may later declare to be heretical a
lesson galileo learned in 1633
when his evidence for the sun-centered
solar system was
fact-checked false by scientific experts
during the inquisition
sometimes scientists cultivate an
invincible image
refusing to share disconfirming evidence
about their work
exactly as feynman invade against
scientists are human
you shouldn't expect scientists to be
free from prejudices that all people
possess
biases like groupthink greed tribalism
and ego ignoring the non-scientific
motivation of scientists is also bad for
science
when a molecular biologist advises who
you should vote for
you may not trust her about the benefits
of a new vaccine
or type of gene therapy so
don't trust me at least not my opinions
about abortion the morality of
capitalism or who to vote for
do listen to scientists about our areas
of expertise
learn from our passionate curiosity
learn from our integrity
and emulate our adversarial yet cordial
approach to converging on truths
ask us questions and demand answers
answers you can
understand your taxes allow us to do our
jobs
but don't expect any special wisdom from
us
that would be most unscientific
[Music]
you